before we continue this video I just
want to say thank you - Layne for
sponsoring this video more on that later
you know there's one misconception that
I hate on the internet they always think
that PM's don't do anything that they
don't add value so what do you say about
that I think it's hard because I think
like there are is there are certain
roles where it's you don't necessarily
need a p.m. if it's purely like
technical looks like sometimes a p.m.
doesn't add any value there but I think
working is like kind of the central
point across all these different like
product functions and helping unblock
and general like being a p.m. the day to
day PM role is not like glamorous right
it's a lot of unblocking a lot of
escalating to other people a lot of
getting people to do things and managing
the project itself like the day-to-day
aspects of it are so like not having
someone to help do that is one
challenging for everyone to get their
job done - it's like I think having a
vision spending having someone spend
time thinking about the overall strategy
and not saying like okay that we only
care about building this one feature but
how do these sets of features like
actually manifest itself into like a
product that actually is something as
special it's like very hard to do when
you're just focusing on a very local
problem right Thomas you need like
someone to look at the prom holistically
to help manage the pieces help break it
up and set timelines and they get like
kind of the work all done otherwise
you've seen at other companies like
there are other companies out there they
don't necessarily have PMS and its
really engineering driven and the
problem is that I've heard from other
friends who work at those companies is
that you build a really cool you want to
build the really cool features and
they're really really like flashy stuff
they're like you would want use but no
one else outside of you or that company
would want to ever use that so you build
really cool features but no one wants to
use them and so it's honestly around
like how do you build how do you build
features and how do you get someone that
understands the what the users actually
want so you also mention like product
vision like that's pretty important
because you can't just focus on
execution but how do you even get better
at product vision since you usually only
vision a few times
right I think you're always thinking
about it okay you always in him but I
think it's a really deeply understanding
in order to get real prog intuition you
have that deeply understanding with the
user problem or customer problem is I
see and that's either doing research or
use it utilizing data and asking the
questions that you need I think those
are the feedback loops that tell you
like oh and reading market research
you're looking at trends things like
that's where it gives you a vision of
like oh this is where the market is
headed or this is where this is where
people are having trouble and that's
helps I craft like oh this is like on
videos right like that means like
discovery might be really hard or people
don't have sets of controls right and so
in that case like you have to really
understand what all these external
signals to help build that intuition
mm-hmm yeah thanks for debunking this
misconception it seems like it's a very
messy job and you're trying to make
things on messy yeah all the time yeah
so because it's so messy - like
unblocked people and do all that crap
like what would make your job easier
for different functions like as a
software engineer how can I make your
job easier as a data science test how
can I make your job easy yeah I think
it's all about just setting like
timelines and deliverables like if you
say if we need this piece of analysis
uh-huh and you can estimate it correctly
to say yeah I'll have it done by the end
of the week and it helps plan things so
there's a chain for it's a chain
reaction right you someone does an
analysis you have recommendations you
then work with design to help like scope
them out they tell you some deadlines
and then engineering can help who can
work on it and so that point if like
those deadlines are not actually like
accurate then it postpones everything
and it makes it pushes things out and so
it's all about just like getting the
proper estimation and chunking it out
into the right set of milestones to make
sure you continue to make progress right
so so being good at estimating how long
it will take certain things yeah right
so do you prefer if someone over
estimates how long it is or
underestimates it's always under promise
over deliver so yeah it's a good motto
always the one thing to keep in the back
of your mind okay yeah I wasn't very
good at estimating when things would be
done it's not necessarily just like a
rating upfront how long it is it just
like if you get three days in the
seven-day analysis and you say oh it's
gonna take longer just
telling people that go this is actually
gonna slip a little bit and show you
then you complain that's true that's
true okay so what about PM's how are
they evaluated then because them it
might be kind of hard because some
products are easier than others
yep for example if the product is
already booming versus a product that's
crap I think it's a couple ways I think
you can do a one on like the product
strategy that you have like did you set
the right vision and as and it not
necessarily be that like you succeeded
but it's also if you failed like did you
learn why you failed that can help
iterate on your product strategy coming
up so it's not just you don't get
rewarded just for succeeding even
actually get rewarded for failing but
failing in the right way so you have the
right hypotheses did all the research
what you built just didn't work out and
then you learn for why it didn't work
out that makes your product stronger so
seconds that's one the second one is
like pure execution right it's like did
you execute on what you were gonna say
you're gonna do I give you have six
months and you have to build something
in six months did you actually build it
and ship it in six months and the last
one is more like kind of
cross-functional it's like did you were
you able to motivate your team did they
like working with you were you able to
unblock them and how is your
relationship with like other teams
outside of your core team and like did
you were able to get like a lot more out
of other people and did they like doing
any soon do you think the skills to pass
the interview as a p.m. are the same as
the skills to be a good PM because I
feel like for software that's not true
yeah right so I think it's software it's
like I think you have to pass some bar
artificial bar like you have to know how
to do all these recursion problems but
like in theory you never do it every
neurons algorithm problems never do it
in theory in practice and Suffragette I
think in product it actually gives you a
good signal I'm like can you take an
ambiguous problem and like break it down
if you take or if you have a really
ambiguous problem and you're not able to
put a framework in place to analyze it
you're never gonna be it's gonna be
really really hard to be successful you
can learn it for sure and then if you
can't like have fluidity with some data
and saying here's I pop this is why
something's down and say here's that
would prove it like you're gonna
struggle like it so I'm not saying as
I'll learn although I think it's just
like there's an effort that you can put
upfront the problem solving to learn and
say like here's how I would think of
stuff that definitely helps so I would
say it's definitely more fair mm-hm I
think the one thing that isn't
necessarily super fair being someone
that's like young is like experience hmm
like the fact that people are looking
for more experienced people like in a
role like if two more years of
experience like and people don't take
you for that role or two years less of
experience for someone else like and the
cotton what they say is like oh you're
not you don't have experience to be in
this role I think that's a little bit
more of a cop-out because it's a matter
of it's just a matter of like how does
this person have the right set of skills
like not necessarily experience matters
that's true so for you especially during
your time at Facebook what skills do you
think were most important to your
success I think it Facebook it's a lot
of just communication like over
communicating realize when you work on
they're really under your team itself
like people understand all the context
for why you're doing things and you
don't need to like you can get really in
the details but if you take a step up
and look at your manager your managed
manager or other teams they lack all
like the individual details and so it's
like keeping those people informed is
that you're working on this this is why
you're working on it makes your life
ways here yeah so I think that's like
one of the biggest skills you've learned
it's actually the big company is like
how do you manage like outside of your
core team is it a small start-up it's
easy because everyone knows what you're
working on you finite resources like
everyone in the company knows exactly
the problems that you're working on or
is a bigger company it's like people are
working on so many different things it's
hard
mm-hmm-hmm so communication matters a
lot what do you hate most about being a
PM
I think there's it's hard I think
there's a lot of unflattering things you
have to do as a p.m. like you have to
like commute over-communicating you have
to unblock and having those like having
to like step through politics and like
and people's incentives is kind of
you're all on the same team and the fact
that people sometimes act like have
different at differing agendas is really
difficult because you have to find why
if I understand it and then sometimes
like it comes to a head if those if
those things are not like a line mm-hmm
and so in that case it's just like
there's a lot of unnecessary roadblocks
for you to do something that you want to
like everyone was agreed to mm-hmm I
think that's like pretty frustrating
because it's inefficient can't give me
an example of what office office
politics actually are because on my
previous video I said something about
office politics for data science and a
lot of people mistook me thinking that I
hate office politic but that is not true
I think off ippolit office politics are
great but I just wish I wasn't better at
it yeah right like I think it's great
like I watch billions that bunch of
office politics or good not great but
but but it's it's so juicy like I like
it
so anyways can you an example what
office politics actually looked like in
real life yeah I think it just mean I
think it's less like contentious is what
people think I think it just means like
you're working with a team that's not
your team right they have different
goals and like they have different
incentives like if you're on that team
like you have a goal you want to hit
like you're not willing to work with
another team because it doesn't mean
that it doesn't help you hit that goal
and so why would you ever want to do
that right and so it's more of like
Howard team's aligned and structure to
make sure like you can reduce that
because like that's just inherent people
are always going to be like I like you
looking out for my team like if that's
not the case like you can't help my team
like why would I work but as in
generally a part of the same company so
I kept understand where they're coming
from mm-hmm nothing really juicy so
right exactly it's not crazy like now
that stabbing is basic here and you just
are just like yeah like it's fair very
fair and people come from the right
place mm-hmm so I just want to take a
second here to talk to you guys about -
Lane - Lane has been a huge time saver
for me so as you know I buy a lot of
[ __ ] so I hate entering my password and
my credit card information every single
time and now with - Lane I don't have to
because every time there's an online
forum it just fills everything out
automatically saving me tons of time and
it keeps everything secured plus if any
of your personal information gets leaked
in the dark web - Lane will alert you
because they are actively monitoring the
darknet for you when you do see your
passwords get leaked all you have to do
is press one single button and it would
change all your passwords for you you
know
I used to have one tasks work for
everything I use all the apps all the
websites which is kind of dumb but now I
take my security pretty seriously they
also have a VPN so you can access
content everywhere and prevent prying
advertisers eyes just joking but
seriously if you're interested you can
get it for free on your first device if
you go on - Ling comm slash Joma
and for my viewers you can get 10% off
premium if you want to use the VPN or
the dark web monitoring now that's
pretty cool alright that's pretty much
it all right do you have any tips for
people who want to transition into p.m.
I know we talked about that a little bit
but just like more concretely yeah I
think like in general it's like just
continue to be thinking about like
products right like products that you
use whether it's like an iPhone a watch
like even not it doesn't have to be
actually like an an electronic product
can be anything news like okay how would
I make this better and then just like
breaking it down in your head like oh
who would I who would use it why would I
want to use it where does this like
where does this like a breakdown how can
what are the things that I can build
that make this better I think it just
helps you look really think about like a
framework right mm-hmm and then I think
like just like understanding more of
like developing hypotheses of like why
you think something's the case and
trying to like prove or disprove it so I
hope you like to develop like the
critical thinking I think understanding
data in general is like is definitely
helpful like being able to learn to
write your own queries like it's not--
though not necessary like it just
helpful understand like how things are
done and if you need to you can do it
yourself and then it's doing it just
like mostly just like curiosity and just
the ability to like really want to dive
deep in a product like for example I was
never a software engineer I didn't know
anything about api's I don't know
anything about developers platforms and
what tools they build but I work for
three years on building developer two
platforms api's and like really
technical solutions without knowing any
of it to start and after that it's like
I you dive deep and understand problems
and you're like okay yeah here's what
the solution is and you
learn and so it's all about like how do
you understand what the problem is you
know the customer the user of the
developer I guess what I meant more was
concretely did you use any resources to
help you prep for matters I know I think
the best way is like just to do as many
mock in and read as you can how do you
get your views I mean if you know
someone at a company with your friends
like you just ask your friend if you
just like give me this prompt and then
just like go through it as like there's
no substitute for like a real experience
they get think about in your head but
actually having to communicate it and
tell people it's a much harder problem
the second thing is just like making
sure you understand how to communicate
and like explain things I think people
think about for me example for example I
think of all the things in my head and
so I understand it but communicating and
proving to someone that you understand a
problem is a much harder thing but with
you can do that it tells them that you
understand you really can understand
what the problem is and so I just say
like do a ton of like mock interviews
with friends like there's some resources
online I didn't look at anybody there's
some resources online that like really
go into like what the types of things
you should look at our there's a lot
yeah there's a really there's a lot of
resources out there any other things it
is help that are helpful like is even if
you just do basic like look at some
basic consulting frameworks like Annie
just helps because understands like how
people think about frameworks and
breaking things down mm-hmm but those
friends they have to be in in PA yeah
they have to be p.m. right yeah I mean
it's kind of hard for some people who
don't have p.m. friends so I mean I
guess you could be cracking the pm
interview yeah I read that I didn't get
the job by I think it's like and a lot
of companies will tell you like how to
how to prep and they'll give you
resources to prep and so you just do it
and you go through it I think a lot of
times I see people and I do interviews
like the resources are all there but you
obviously didn't read them and so like
it's not like it's not rocket science to
go through this is just all about the
structure and the framing that you have
let's go to like the personal stuff I
write more about you alright you know so
like why did you choose pin one I wasn't
good enough to be the software engineer
I was you were you directly make
strictly mediocre oh you wouldn't want I
think was driving in general it was very
interest like for me it's like what's
really interesting to build things or
just see like to write light a couple
lines of code and see something happen
immediately and I think that was like
where it was like oh I want to I don't
want to work in like client services I
don't want to do other things I want to
work I don't know what do you sales
write because I want to go like actually
build the things that like people use
and I it's like if you I'm not a
software engineer like what are the
types of things you can do right you can
start a company or you can work it like
the product manager and own a product
and build it from end to end and have a
team built teamwork team working with
you to build it as well and so it's more
around like how do I just I see all this
could these cool things in slope and
valley like outside of Silicon Valley
like how do you how can I build
something like that it so it's more
around like that type of mentality and
product gave me the best chance to do it
did you build anything when you were a
kid or when you're yeah yeah I was
actually super into I thought I wanted
to be like a mechanical engineer or like
something like a material science or
stuff like that or I we had this class
in high school or we built we built
engines we built like we actually
measured we built like cosmic ray
finders and we were able to like kind of
do really cool we're gonna do kind of
build really cool things in a class and
I think that was just really fun to get
experience building like mechanical
stuff but then I took a couple classes
in college around like building web apps
oh well that I thought it was really
really cool to just build something
uh-huh and I think I'd want to say ever
to like the first class you take is like
CS 106a oh really I do anyone all right
everyone has one ninety five or nine
years adopts over 95% of the undergrad
class that takes us seriously
my class is like a thousand two hundred
people holy but the last project you
build is I mean the projects you build
are one you build a rip breaker I can't
believe you still write it III mean I
can't believe you did that too because I
still see some people building that yeah
it's a very common it's a growing ro and
the last one was to build a watered down
version of Facebook really I had the
basic functionality a friend request Wow
I'm riding on things and
this year yeah and so the ability you
can actually see that and build it uh
maybe was definitely a little bit yeah
you had some of the starter packages for
it but like the fact that you're able to
build and see like oh my lines
correspond to this stuff it was really
cool Wow no wonder why Stanford such a
good school holy all right so a little
bit more philosophical yeah you know
what are you working towards in life
yeah pick it if I thought I definitely
had some point I want to like start a
company or doing something really small
right I think the problem the problem I
see a lot is like people start companies
for the sake of starting companies
because they think it's like a quick way
to get rich the end of the day like
that's not gonna have like odds are so
much against you that like it the only
way it's gonna during give yourself the
best chance of succeeding is if you're
really passionate about that area and
willing to spend ten fifteen years like
building it even if it even if it might
fail right and so it's like I think the
the only way I would think about
starting a company is like if if I had
enough conviction motivation honest with
a problem to solve it otherwise like I
think I'm joining a company super small
where like you help build the product
from scratch but I sort of come with the
idea it's something that's really
fascinating because I how do you bring
something that's super small of this
scale like hopefully grow it so that's
kind of where I want to go I think I've
learned some pretty really pretty good
skills now in order to do it in the
future they're nice well it's a true
bill that you are that's nice but what
what kind of problems would you like to
solve like what are the areas that you
care about like there's a lot of stuff
that happens to John just like getting
people to use more things right like I
mean I work on products that do the same
thing right but I think there's
something around like some of the social
good around like health right how do you
make things health more accessible and
some of the more societal level problems
that people are trying to tackle but
it's much trickier right health is one
well being that what you care about
something about how I see something
about I see something that makes an
impact like in people's lives if it's
like money transfer to to rural
countries and making it easy for people
to Bank right like I think that's
something that you can just see impact
of a product
building I guess you can build a product
that's cool but seeing people use it in
a ways that like actually changes their
lives like I think it's something that
would I would love to do if this mission
is more mission driven cool yeah I think
we're doing stuff around like sports
it's also super interesting like I think
there's so much date like so much data
out there to make like better decisions
from like your sleep to your health to
your performance that doesn't exist I'm
saying that's a really super interesting
piece as well as education all these
like things where people can like you
can actually see people have fundamental
changes and like well-being is I think
something that is interesting onward
nice nice yeah just to make sure that
your incentives are are true so if every
job paid the same mm-hmm what would you
do oh if every single drop paid the same
like I personally this is gonna be able
at a left field but I think I want to
work in like the State Department the
State Department the government I think
it'd be really cool to be like work in
foreign affairs and work like with kind
of governmental policy across like
foreign policy across like different
parts of the world I think it's hard to
get into it I think it's like the
process Biko working in the government
it's like very antiquated or it's just
like there's no real good career
trajectory but I think that's like super
interesting - oh that's true that's cool
so what about now like what do you do
outside of work let's not talk about
what do you do outside of work that I
love me like I love being outdoors I
love like a content I love being a
content being hiking I would go hiking
going skiing I love traveling oh yeah
I'm going to Japan in a couple days oh
really yeah dude everyone's going to
Jannah
cool all right thank you so much for
coming in yeah appreciate it yeah all
right
see ya